der bestimmende nicht und damit herzlich
willkommen hier heute meine lieben
freunde zu einer neuen episode hiervon
ja das ist ganz einfach nur pink
wir machen hier heute endlich mal wieder
ein würdest du akvis von daher würde ich
sagen fangen wir damit der ersten frage
der wir uns heute stellen müssen
julia hefty of light delayed by eight
hours oder lucia luggage acht stunden
sprachen lernen müssen 100-prozentig
würde ich lieber meinen flug acht
stunden später nehmen müssen als mein
komplettes gepäck zu verlieren weil ich
meine müssten erforschen und pizza im
gepäck frage nummer zwei bei der lieben
zuschauer wohl thierry henry hub button
in your life oder post baten in your
life
[Musik]
also würde ich lieber sagen können hey
ich würde ganz zurückspulen oder ich
würde gerade pausieren safe der rivale
button einfach so das ist jetzt zwar ein
bisschen dieb aber leute die man
vielleicht früher kannte und die jetzt
nicht mehr leben oder nicht mehr teil
des eigenen lebens sind dann kann man
noch mal momente mit denen ja also
hundertprozentig der rivale button das
tolle an diesem würdest du er videos ist
ja dass ihr auch einfach in den
kommentaren mit raten können
beziehungsweise einfach eure meinung
auch mit unten in die kommentare
reinschreiben können das wäre mégane
können uns darauf ein bisschen
unterhalten können so sagen hey was
haltet ihr besser weil wofür hättet ihr
euch entschieden allerdings ist das ihr
seht ihr schon die nächste frage und
zwar wird die rather be able to talk
with the animals oder speed or foreign
language oh mein gott
j
würde ich lieber mit allen tieren
sprechen können oder alle sprachen
sprechen können bei dieser frage muss
sich allerdings jetzt auch wieder nach
einer gewissen überlegung zeit ganz klar
antworten und zwar würde ich natürlich
die wahl mit tieren sprechen können weil
mit den menschen auch aus anderen
ländern kann man sich ja immer noch auf
englisch irgendwie verständigen wir
machen allerdings weltweit sie mit der
vierten frage wohl ua windeler oder lift
weiß es nicht entscheiden und ich bin
ganz ehrlich bei den bisherigen fragen
die wir hatten habe ich nach einer
gewissen überlegung dauer haben ja auch
wirklich immer sagen können hey das 100
prozent da kam das andere dann gar nicht
mehr in frage aber hier jetzt gerade bin
laden wie oder lift weiß als long ich
weiß es einfach nicht wäre ich lieber
komplett reich und wird mein leben was
ich halt habe so leben wie ich leben
möchte in meinen kühnsten träumen oder
wäre ich nicht total reich und lebe
einfach doppelt so lange
ich glaube ich wird doppelt so lang
leben wollen sonst kommen wir allerdings
nur noch schon zur fünften frage für das
heutige video und zwar ist die frage
what you'll be batman oder wie spiderman
ich wäre gern überhaupt irgendjemand mit
muskeln also spiderman ist eine halbe
spinne also er kann ja aus seinem
handgelenk also spinnenweben rauscher
die griechen fliegen aber was batman so
richtig kann weiß ich jetzt gar nicht so
genau der hut sein anzug und hut halt
trasse technik und irgendwie sollte sein
batmobil und seine höhle also ich würde
mich für spiderman entscheiden weil ich
dann halt durch städte mich hangeln kann
kommen wir allerdings nur noch schon zur
sechsten frage mensch das geht ja voran
wie schmidts katze what you're the beast
akne brocken skilift oder wie stuck in
broken elevator
boah
boah ich finde ich finde es kommt drauf
an eigentlich würde ich direkt aus der
pistole geschossen sagen wie stark eine
brocken elevator weil fahrstühle haben
wir 1000 sicherheitsmechanismen also das
passiert dann eigentlich nichts und wenn
ein sonnenschirm teil stehen bleibt denn
da kommt krankheit wind oder irgendwie
so wo sonst der skilift einfach jetzt
gar nicht fahren würde man da allerdings
darin setzt deshalb blöd allerdings ist
man beim skilift an der frischen luft
das heißt man kann da leute also da bin
ich mir wirklich 50 50 da bin ich auf
eure antworten den kommentaren gespannt
wir machen allerdings weiter mit der
siebte frage wo tschira diese most
popular school oder dieses wortes person
ad school safe smart ist das hat mir
meine eltern auch früher schon immer
gesagt so ey versuchen nicht irgendwie
der coolste oder der klassenclown zu
sein klar das ist lustig während der
schulzeit und damit der bekannteste der
ganzen stufe und leute die die später
was zu was bringen und was schaffen sind
halt nicht diese dummen bekannten hey
guck mal da war der hat er gegen die
tafel gebildet oder ist voll cool
sondern das sind halt die schlauen die
später zu was bringen also bei der
siebten frage vorhin hätte ich mich auch
definitiv wieder für das rechte
entschieden also lieber bietet smart ist
als dass sich die bekannteste person in
der ganzen schule bin das ist jetzt
allerdings schon die achte frage und
zwar mit you'll have you or close also
du müsstest alle deine klamotten selber
nähen oder goya on food
was
so sei es komplett falsch verstanden ich
dachte man müsse sich jetzt entscheiden
zwischen hey du musst alle deine
klamotten selber nähen oder du darfst
sein eigenes essen an pflanzen sondern
hätte ich das rechte genommen
aber ich würde auch so dass rechte
nehmen also wenn ich alle meine
klamotten selber nennen müsste oder mir
mein eigenes essen anbauen das heft das
eigene essen anbauen die leute frage
wurde jura verlief in der antarktis oder
liv in der sahara wüste also würde ich
lieber eben der kompletten kälte wohnen
wollen oder in der kompletten hits ich
glaube in der kälte bei mir se nie so
schnell kalt war ich halt ziemlich heiß
wir sind mittlerweile schon mit der
zehnten frage angelangt wird jura the
body wie vor dem rest of my life oder
oder junk food for the rest of your life
ins ist mit beide scheißegal
also mir ist egal ob ich nie wieder
einen fernseher haben so manche halt
alles am handy oder ob ich nie wieder
fast food hat mich glaube wenn ich mich
entscheiden müsste dann dauert junkfood
weil dann ist man automatisch lebt man
auch noch genügen frage nummer elf meine
lieben freunde oder spendet daily news
mit park oder lane on the beach safe der
strand hundertprozentig ich sehe den
sinn von freizeitparks nicht wann steht
stundenlang in irgendwelchen
warteschlangen an für irgendwelche
rollercoaster achterbahnen und keine
ahnung was vor allem einfach nur
schlecht wird also ich sehe da wirklich
den sinnlich dann liege ich lieber am
strand
allerdings ist das ist schon die nächste
frage wo traditon ibiza vorjahr nur
pizza was das juckt mich eiskalt safe
pizza frage nummer 13 da bin ich jetzt
auch schon mal gespannt
laut it would you ever change my carla
oder the change your hair colour ich bin
eigentlich also das ist eine allgemeine
sache ich bin jetzt gar keinen menschen
jetzt irgendwie sagt verläuft schmerz im
rechten bein vom fußball damals mein
leben mit scheiße oder ob ich meine
haare immer die wachsen falls schnell
oder so ich will mich eigentlich nicht
über das beschweren weil
wie ich bin weil so bin ich halt da
finde ich aber auch eure meinung in den
kommentaren mal wieder extrem
interessant also ihr könnt mir einfach
zu jeder frage unten hin schreiben wie
ihr euch entschieden hätte zum beispiel
hier frage 14 would you are the family
of truth children also hättest du lieber
zwölf kinder oder never be able to have
killed 01 11 12 von mir auf 20 alter das
ich finde kinder erst erst kinder machen
wirklich das komplette leben lebenswert
versteht ihr was ich meine frage nummer
15 ich weiß ehrlich gesagt gar nicht
genau wie viele fragen überhaupt noch
haben mit ihrer single pflaster oder
kugler gourmet chef ich würde nie singen
ich find ich finde singen denn es gibt
ja leute die wirklich sagen wo ich würde
so gerne richtig toll singen können
warum warum ich schätze ich würde lieber
kochen
obwohl ich glaube ich bin gerade nochmal
umgeschwenkt bei meiner entscheidung
weil ich mir gedacht habe
kochen da braucht man kein talent für so
das kann man sich bei bringen aber
singen wir schon gut wenn man da ganz
gute gene sage ich mal hat deswegen
würde ich mich doch für sich entscheiden
allerdings kommen wir zu dieser frage ja
brother mentally age oder never physical
okay das ist dass das ist schwierig also
die frage an alle englisch legastheniker
hier draußen noch mal übersetzen würde
die er niemals mental altern also dass
man immer fit im job im kopf oder
niemals von außen also erstmal keine
falten bekommt ich habe absolut keine
ahnung stimmt mal hier oben ab ich
glaube das wird von fiftyfifty ding will
man entweder sein leben lang jung
aussehen oder sein leben lang fit im
kopf sein
ich glaube ich weiß es gar nicht ich
glaube ich würde nie mentally age nehmen
ich bin mir überhaupt nicht sicher haben
wir nun allerdings auch schon zuletzt in
frage für heutigen video und zwar frage
nummer 17 und jura hat abi gewinne
lifetime supply of food oder lifetime
supply of low
also wer da überlegt hat den verstand
verloren
man kann sich entscheiden zwischen
lebenslanger vorrat an klamotten oder
essen was ist das grundbedürfnis
schlechthin für einen menschen ist es
essen oder ist es klamotten oder ist es
vielleicht sogar an der stelle durch das
heute videos eigentlich auch beenden
meine lieben freunde und abholung camino
shop und geh ich habe ich hier das bunte
kissen in der hand das vor einigen
monaten bereits im lokal - shopping.de
gelaunt ist sagen wir 1000 stück
herausgebracht die waren allerdings nach
minuten ausverkauft deswegen haben jetzt
gesagt wir bestellen noch mal 1000 stück
nach und in zweieinhalb wochen habe ich
geburtstag und zwar im 21ten zweiter
werden diese kissen noch mal rauskommen
sie 1000 stück genug geben ab 15 uhr am
21 22
also schaut dort gern vorbei zu jeder
bestellung gibt es eine persönlich von
mir signierte autogrammkarte schreibt
mir gerne zu leben und in die kommentare
wofür ihr euch entschieden hätte bei den
verschiedenen fragen heute ich hoffe
euch das video gefallen und ich
ich bin ich bin dumm
[Musik]